blue light cav show we got a special
guest in here um
representing a couple of cities hey one
six six one six
sleazy world is here yeah see world go
welcome man
um first of all
a lot of jewelry man
i gotta say most young artists who
just catching their wave ain't as icy as
you so
things are going well for you i see yeah
things are going well uh yo kansas city
man um
you know i'm real tight with tech nine
and the strange music guys and i feel
like forever they've kind of been the
only thing really nationally popping out
of the city so like
you know are you like hip to like the
tech nine [ __ ] at all i know it's like a
whole different world you know what i
mean but in terms of like you know he's
he's kind of the face of casey or he's
been for a very long time are you kind
of hip to his movement and
for sure he's a legend definitely take
none
you guys like connect at all no we ain't
talking none yet
i'm pretty sure it's gonna happen soon
it's got to man he's got like a crazy
compound out there that's like
buildings i heard about it car washes
and
all kinds of wild [ __ ] man how long have
you been making music
uh
i probably dropped my first single
two years ago
yeah and it was just up like was it up
right away or was it kind of like a slow
build
uh it was kind of up right away but like
it wasn't like you know
mainstream uh but it was like right but
it was good but you were doing numbers
yeah you were like oh [ __ ] there's
something here pretty much right away
you like realize you you had something
in my first my first video probably did
like 300 000. that's amazing yeah yeah
that's crazy real views yeah that's the
important part a lot of people's first
video does 300 000 views but they're all
fake and there's like four comments you
know what i mean not facts
um so yo ma'am well first of all let's
start with your name how'd you get you
how'd you get your name
uh
sleazy world go me and my cousin we was
really just like
trying to figure out a name like right
before i dropped my first song or
whatever it's that's really what we came
up with like my rap name really was
supposed to be go but like everybody
started calling me sleazy like sleazy
world that's just us our group that's
the crew sleazy world is the crew yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying so i added
the goal in there like for me you know
all my other bros and [ __ ] they [ __ ]
like sleazy world two eyes sleazy world
baghdad you know what i'm saying but
my fans started calling me sleazy and i
just ran with it it made sense
just you don't want to run into what
happened with the ybn kids when they
broke up what because you know there was
like why be in the mirror why being
almighty j and then why being court and
then cord dropped the ybn and then it
was just you know
i mean
because there i'm assuming that you have
other artists in the crew right
are you the only artist i'm the only
artist my brother here artist 81 hundo
okay
you know what i'm saying he got his own
little [ __ ] grimy game so you're
originally from grand rapids gun rule
shout out to grand rapids um and then
you ended up moving to casey
yeah so what was like that timeline
uh around when i was like 13. so i've
been in kansas city since
four minutes now so so you've been in kc
for a minute so you're pretty much kind
of repping casey but like your roots
were in yeah grand rapids grand rapids
you know that's the hometown i always
gotta you know that's what i was born
that you still got a bunch of family
there
ah my sister i got a couple
cousins the aunties
but like most of my family live in
kansas city
so i noticed um
in your videos there may or may not be a
lot of weapons now whether or not those
are real weapons or toy guns is besides
the point with that being said
we just saw what happened with thug and
ysl and how they're using some of the
music and the videos against them is
that something that like you see and you
kind of like
you know again
prop guns are a great thing shout out to
the prop guns and the toy guns but i
mean in general like when you see some
[ __ ] like that happen does it kind of
make you reconsider some of the [ __ ] you
might put in videos i mean
i don't really know that situation so i
can't really like speak too much on it
so like i don't really i'm not really
hip to like
really happen or what's going on with
that situation i just know that like in
general every time there's like some
crazy case it seems like they're using
people's videos and lyrics against them
like
lyrics like i ain't really seen too many
use like videos not like that i really
see him using lyrics
right
so it's like really about what you
saying in your songs like you know what
i'm saying yeah just got to be careful
what you're saying or not no for sure
and like also like for you like
now that you realize like [ __ ] i got you
know you got a bright future ahead of
you man like i was just telling you
you're dope like there's people who
catch a record and like you could kind
of tell that like
all right well you caught one like
congrats enjoy the next like 18 months
of like
getting bags of clubs and you know
whatever but like i i see you having
like longevity if you really do this the
right way so like
are you like conscientious in that and
making sure you kind of have your eyes
dotted your t's crossed in terms of just
like how you're moving and the things so
like i make sure
everything i'm doing it's like you know
what i'm saying i'm thinking before i'm
making decisions so it's like that's how
i got to where i'm at now mm-hmm this
thing is smart moving right correctly so
like
yeah
what's the temperature like in kc
because it's a city i don't think a lot
of like a lot of people don't know about
kansas city we know about jacksonville
we know about chicago we know about
what's going on everywhere else but like
casey is a new kind of a new place when
it comes to like hip-hop like i said we
really just know about tech man casey
lit you gotta just come down the
experience rest in peace matt dre is
where matt drake was murdered you know
what i mean casey lit you just got to
come down there and survive you know
it's a culture it's like this is a
different world you know you just got to
be there and see
experience it live see what's going on
like it's definitely violence in the
city it's violent scenario city so
i'm hearing uh you guys might have the
best barbecue
no we got the best barbecue
because there's like
there's kansas city barbecue then
there's
memphis
and then there's
texas austin texas we got the best
barbecue though
for sure for sure
has uh anybody on the chiefs tapped in
with you
uh
patrick mahomes whack-ass brother do a
tick-tock to your song yet
what up y'all hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our partners
the presenting sponsor of the bootleg
kit podcast our family at odds socks man
they're dropping so much heat at odd
socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddssoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
y'all know patrick mahomes brother be
making y'all look crazy in casey jackson
holmes wilin i mean a lot of like nfl
players and tapped into me definitely a
couple chief players i don't know like
they probably they they usually hit me
up on the ground i had to check like my
uh request or whatever but like it's a
lot of football players to hit me up but
i'm definitely going to type in most of
them yeah you got to tap in with the
chiefs man you guys got one of the best
teams in the last like five years you
know what i mean patrick mahomes is an
alien yeah yeah
do you um when it comes to like um
your writing process you know a lot of
times people they do the punch in thing
they don't write anything down are you
like what is your creative process in
the studio are you writing [ __ ] in your
phone are you just punching in line by
line like what do you do
i punch in but i um
i write it down like so like i can have
legs
you know
but yeah i punch in i don't really write
so you don't write it's just like yo you
just hear the beat you go in and from
there this is what we get yeah i write
it down after it's like like after i
punch it i'll write whatever i'll say it
down
uh what has been your personal favorite
remix to your record because we've
gotten a bunch a lot of people have
remixed your song my personal favorite
would probably be uh
[Music]
let me see
i don't know they are really good though
i know nle did one did ace do one young
ace yeah probably my favorite young and
ace yeah shout out to young
how many like who what were some of the
other notable ones that happened because
i know choppa ace
i think i'm missing at least one other
that were kind of that was bigger
i don't know a lot of people didn't date
them when you get a record like that do
you kind of know right away that
this record might change your life or is
it just like another one in the clip
that happens to just kind of do its
thing
yeah i mean it changed my life but like
that record i knew it was gonna go crazy
i just ain't like feel like it was gonna
go crazy that fast like or like what it
was doing like everybody want to remix
it you know like it's kind of like
becoming part of history
it's crazy because uh with a record like
that you could do like sequels to the
song
you know what i'm saying like i wanna do
sequels to it though
because i think like how like nle milk
like shadow flow like he there's like
eight of them you know what i mean like
like you could do like
part two part three is there gonna be
official remix
yeah it's gonna be a remix to it but i
wouldn't do no sequels to it just
because like that's like his own like i
said it's like part of history now so
right
yeah um
have any idea who's on the remix shot
uh
i know who on the moon but you know
yeah can we get can we get a hint okay
how about this give me uh a city that
one of the artists is from
i don't know this record they part of
sleazy world so that's where we at
this is such a this guy they train him
so well
look at him he's not giving me
nothing um
it's going to be some it's going to be a
big feature on them man a big feature
[Music]
what city are they from
i told you
they in my world so they they're in your
world they said they're not from are
they from kansas city you got tech nine
on the [ __ ] remix
that'd be hard though i'm really good at
guessing these things if you just give
me the city i might get it you don't
have to confirm or disconfirm
hmm
i don't know
we lit though
is it chicago
no it's not chicago
okay
you can't go guess that [ __ ] all
right that's coming soon though so it's
coming real soon i was about to say it's
about time right like i feel like the
remix is timing is like perfect like so
um are you and you just showed me a new
video that you got coming out that's
crazy for the record that is kind of you
previewed that's going doing this thing
on tick tock it's been going crazy step
one
um have you do you feel like you've
mastered tick tock because i feel like
it's an art form to that [ __ ] low-key in
it and you kind of have to be on there
as an artist
i feel like you just got to be on there
as a person period like tick-tock like
you know what i'm saying it's a it get
everybody like a voice you know like you
ain't really got to be you ain't really
got to be nobody you can make some [ __ ]
it'll blow up you know what i'm saying
so it's like
and it's like it's different than all
the other social medias you know it's
addictive yeah everybody's [ __ ]
scrolling up everybody in bed i don't
matter who you is
you know i've probably i'm probably the
last person in my life i know that
hasn't i don't open tick tock i don't
really open to talk either because i see
my wife she'll be on that [ __ ] she'll
be on her i'll have a whole podcast on
tv she don't take type she's just on
tick tock she don't give a [ __ ] i could
be watching literally whatever i want
that she's not into because she's on her
[ __ ] phone swiping up all kinds of
goofy ass [ __ ]
dog tick tocks cat tick tocks all kinds
of ill [ __ ] man nah tic toc that's like
probably one of the biggest impactful
platforms that's going on right now
but like do i feel like i mastered it i
want to say that i just post regular
[ __ ] that's normal for me
how old are you man 24. 24. so you're
still very young guy um you know uh and
if you're you say you dropped your first
record two years ago how many years ago
was this yeah like two years ago that
shit's crazy
that's not normal
two-year process i should feel like the
two years so you drop did you drop your
first song during the pandemic
right before probably like
a week or two before the pandemic hit
jesus
pandemic is the best thing to happen for
you huh best thing to happen i ain't
gonna lie the pandemic was lit for me
what'd you do like when you were um
growing up man did you like what were
you doing in high school were you
a good student an athlete like what kind
of [ __ ] were you like getting into i
wasn't really in high school when i was
in high school i had dropped out i
dropped out of like middle school so
like oh you stopped going like what year
like eighth grade ninth grade probably
like the seventh grade i stopped going
to school i started i started going to
school in like the ninth grade but i
wasn't really going to school like i
leave here i leave every time at lunch
did they make you go to like one of them
continuance like bad kid schools no i
was in regular school
public school you know they got that
school like where the girl gets pregnant
she ends up at the other school
and they got the daycare there you know
what i mean yeah i really want to get
into like no bashing in school so they
won oh nothing like that i just wasn't
going to school why weren't you going
[ __ ] i wouldn't i'd rather been in the
streets i was stuck and i wasn't even
trying to be in school for
um are you um do you feel like you're
finally like both fit both foot like all
feet out of the streets both feet in on
your career
yeah
uh that's what i'm working towards
that's good man cause it's
like yeah no i mean i think like uh you
gotta just be careful because you're in
a position to like
win bro you know what i mean not for
sure
is it is it um
and and the the one thing is
we always see people get the most hate
in their hometown
you know what i mean do you feel like
you get like your biggest haters are
from back home
i mean
for sure other cities don't really be
hating because they don't know you but
like
it'd be some hate there but it's like
more love it's like the more they hate
the more the people that's in the city
they start to love me because they're
like you know what i'm saying y'all just
hating right right right i'm saying
like let's let him get his shine on
whatever like
it's more love than hate
but you definitely get the most hate out
your hometown because people feel like
you should have been me type [ __ ] you
know yeah like [ __ ] don't like
seeing people make it you know what i'm
saying especially if it ain't them or
mm-hmm
nobody close to them you know what i'm
saying so like they gonna do
i i realize like
when you make it a [ __ ] gonna do
anything to discredit
that's real
you know what i'm saying or try to take
that take that from me you know what i'm
saying
like you can you can yo i'm saying win a
lottery a [ __ ] gonna try to say
something about something else
take the focus off of you winning some
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying that's
real yeah
uh what's the scene like out there man
like is there any other dope artists on
the come up outside of your crew that
you're [ __ ] with that you know you
could put us up on uh
right money we got d walk up in kansas
city uh my brother out of grand rapids
81 hundo
my [ __ ] 81 wu you know what i'm saying
they are part of uh grimy games so they
going crazy down there
uh it was calais 246. he up in kansas
city with it like them some of the
artists that i listened to when i fought
with fire i got talent kansas city man
it's like uh
yeah it's it's like
it's crazy because it's kind of like a
mate like i feel like any team any city
that has an nfl team besides green bay
it's like should be looked at like it's
like a big city you know what i'm saying
forget about my [ __ ] nb5a2 nb5a is he
here right now
you're pointed over he's here
um
are you working on a project or you're
just doing singles what are we doing i
got a project coming in june
how many songs
i'm gonna say like 14
i don't know
six probably got like 16 of them like
that [ __ ] like an album but it's
a mixtape book i mean listen bro what
are what what is an album and what is a
mixtape
everything ends up on [ __ ] dsps right
for sure but that [ __ ] pressure
like it's an album it's going to get
treated like an album i feel like it's
going to go crazy like i want to go
crazy you know how you got any features
on there well you're not going to tell
me about them so it doesn't matter
you're just going to tell me about your
boys who were on there but nobody have
notoriety right because [ __ ] me right
every feature on there
of course
anybody you want to tell us about
every feature on there can i get one
[ __ ] feature
one give me throw me a bone here man
i'm about to give you some hundo my
brother he like the biggest feat showing
anyone hunt okay well listen if you
[ __ ] drop this project and you know
nba young boys on there or something i'm
gonna we're gonna i gotta you i'm gonna
start classifying you as a liar like
this man just came and lied to me the
first time we ever met you know what i
mean but not yet my brother he'll never
like
your blood brother blood brother that's
tight so who taught who had a rap
uh
nobody thought either had a rap we just
figured out doing that damn what are you
doing in your spare time are you
watching netflix you're playing 2k like
what do you what do you got going on
like any hobbies that that are wild that
we don't know about i don't do [ __ ] like
my spare time i got to focus on my my
kids you know i'm saying if i ain't with
my son or not like that
it don't really make sense because i'd
be happy to leave so much so like my
spare time that's what i'm focused on
how many uh well you only have one ton
no i got two two how old are they uh
my son birthday tomorrow you're gonna be
one one yeah you still are you changing
shitty diapers
no i don't change the life of them
his mama changed her nose really you got
to change the shitty diaper man it's
definitely like a rite of passage as a
father
you get a little bit of [ __ ] on your
hand you know what i mean
you're like i'm like i changed my kid's
diaper and he had diarrhea and that [ __ ]
shot out and hit me in the shirt it was
a bad look yo what up man we got to stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our good folks at blue chew that's
right go to bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
chew
it is the wave uh how about this the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis getting delivered right to your
door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all
online zero awkward visits to the
doctor's office zero you go online you
sign up with the promo code bootleg
that's right bootleg when you check out
you will get the first month for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars on
shipping and you're gonna get one
month's supply of blue chew all right
and you're gonna be [ __ ] like you
were [ __ ] never [ __ ] before your
dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and sucked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com and use
that promo code bootleg and get your
first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechew.com let's get back to the
interview let's [ __ ] the knife i used to
uh change backwards nothing like green
baby [ __ ] because it's all green at
first yeah
it's a bad look yeah changing i mean
listen shout out to your baby mom who's
obviously a queen because she's changing
the diapers not effects yeah no you got
a good one because most of them are like
[ __ ] you it's your turn you know what i
mean
um what's like what has fatherhood
change do you think
uh
i wouldn't say it changed me but like
that [ __ ] made me more happy as like
just in life right like my
my kids really my happiness so like yeah
it ain't really too much should i be
happy about but
beside your kids what makes you happy
man
see nothing forever nothing
not even like uh you get a platinum
plaque or a gold plaque for this lit are
you gonna be happy that's not gonna make
you happy it's gonna make me happy but
like far as like
just like
making me happy in life type [ __ ] like
my kids was making me happy like before
before them i really weren't happy were
you was you happy when the chiefs won
the super bowl
yeah yeah but that [ __ ] like temporary
happening it takes a little bit like a
yeah
yeah it takes it's you know were you
unhappy when tyree kill got traded to
the dolphins
are you like that much are you like a
big football fan i'm like i'm we're
diving in here on chiefs politics i
don't know i'm not a big football fan
right when it comes to the chiefs i'm
watching that [ __ ]
what about the royals you watch baseball
no one watches baseball
great hat though it's one of the best
hats in the game that kc hat is [ __ ]
clean all right yeah so you can't wear
that [ __ ] up listen if you guys come to
la
just watch where you wear the kc hat at
because certain areas you cannot wear
that hat you can't wear that
[ __ ] any hat in general in los
angeles you have to be extremely
cautious with where you are wearing it
if you're in the valley you're fine but
if you go to like la la you will get
pressed for
99 of the hats yeah just a black dodgers
hat safe bet
shout out to dj head he taught me this
but yeah yeah there's there's hats that
you wouldn't even guess like
whatever you do don't wear a [ __ ]
houston astros hat yeah stay away from
that you know what i mean but yeah the
hat politics and alienware uh are you
getting out out here to la like more are
you traveling more now that you're
obviously lit as [ __ ] i'm always
traveling man i ain't never got no break
i'm always traveling doing some shows
doing interviews you know yeah me
meeting a lot of people so like that's
what i'm saying like when i ain't doing
that you're with the kids with the kids
um
is that are you accessible to the point
where like if someone wanted to like
let's say you're in a city doing a show
they pulled up with the bag you are you
doing the feature
i mean i don't really i'm not really big
on features i don't really do features
like that
so
it really depends on
what it what they talking about like
fire's money-wise
what what would be the price hey let's
let's let's solicit right now what's the
feature going for
someone's got 30 bands you're doing the
feature i'm assuming yeah i'm doing it
for the 30 for the 30 boy of course are
you doing the video though
you're doing the the two for i'll do the
two for the 30 ball but like that's not
bad it ain't bad and it's like you know
what i'm saying that's like five
and then you let them deal with the
headache of having your label clear the
verse
like yo you guys clear it
he said ain't clear and [ __ ] we already
got the money bro
[ __ ]
nah um that's what's up man well look uh
hopefully we can you say project's
coming in june june 16th
like
damn
jay
you heard him
what did you say is coming up
well i guess it's june 16th
well i actually meant
june 16th when i'm [ __ ] coming up
so i actually was refer i was referring
to the amount of songs on the project
but you just let us know june 16th is
when the project's coming out
so that'll be nice now just give us a
feature
who's on the remix
what hey what
what hey what day is uh what day is the
remix coming out i mean that [ __ ] gotta
be soon man that [ __ ] coming out
soon that [ __ ] might come out
tomorrow
watch my page
make sure you follow my [ __ ] leave the
world underscore go on instagram man
that [ __ ] might come out
tomorrow cow
okay
so big remix
with someone from chicago
someone from atlanta
someone from
sleazy world los angeles
um
who would you say your biggest
influences are man
uh my biggest influence like musically
obviously like
um
i don't really feel like um i'm
influenced by no artist it's artists
that i like you know
i like they craft i like what they doing
you know what i'm saying so like who's
like who did you like if you had to give
us your top three or four artists that
you just like listen to all the time
yeah that are just your your go-to
uh i'm gonna say kodak railway
um a couple of florida boys
call that railway so kodak black's gonna
be
no cap's fire okay bro he's hard so yeah
and he don't write nothing down yeah i
heard he's like a savant in the studio i
don't know we need a feature though
shout out to he's from alabama yeah
shout out to alabama man all right you
gotta give me one more one more artist
you love one more article you're
listening to uh
i'm gonna name like an underground one
okay give me an underground though
um
[Music]
i gotta check him out let's take him out
you listen to any l.a [ __ ]
uh
ain't jay but from l.a oh he's from
sacramento
sacramento or stockton stockton yeah oh
stockton yeah oh yeah i know who it is
stockton stockton's lit have you been to
stockton no [ __ ] crazy place man
you should go you [ __ ] with mazzy at all
yeah i [ __ ] with mazzy mazzy from
sacramento you guys should work together
maji was like my favorite artist for a
long time no cap as he should be because
he's a [ __ ] beast you are
you guys should work together yeah yeah
let me know how long are you in l.a
uh for a couple days i ain't really down
here for that long it's making shows
coming up like right after this [ __ ] get
you in the studio with mazzy white right
here yeah that's easy his studio is like
across the street on facts yeah good guy
we need that fee so you were like really
tapped in with mazzy pryor like because
you know but people are finally like
[ __ ] uh hopping on his dick because
he signed a yo gotti but i'm like mazzy
been that guy for like 10 years
yeah man
you gotta think about it ken city like
that's what he was listening to like you
know i'm saying
in one of the cities that supported him
the most like you know yeah kc for
whatever reason has like a real
connection with like northern cali
in terms of the mu i mean i kind of have
an idea of why
may or may not have to do with pax but
you know i set out to say that like
there's always kind of been like a a
connection between like the bay
northern cali and casey and like even
like detroit detroit folks at the bay
tough like
but now like
can't see you like we we used to slap
him before [ __ ] even
knew about him like he was just coming
up you know what i'm saying
that's big shout out to kc man i got to
get out there and [ __ ] with y'all yeah
um what is your if you if you
say someone's coming to your city and
they want to try the absolute
single go-to place to eat
what is that one spot
i mean me personally i [ __ ] with lemon
pepper wings and chinese food
combination for all right so it's like
if you asking me i'm gonna tell you to
go to like
you can you get those at the same place
out there yeah yeah
nice oh the seafood best seafood in the
world golden seafood that's what it's
called you know there's not like an
ocean near kansas city so like we're
sure that that's the spot i mean i get
combination fried rice from man that's
it fast okay what about what about
barbecue what's the barbecue spot is it
just everywhere
[Music]
yeah i'll never be like let's go get
some barbecue okay
look go tap in uh the new project june
16th right i don't know that movie
something like it
something like it
in june can we get the name
i don't know if it called come on
it's called come here yeah i like that
is that what you tell a [ __ ] when you
see her come here come on i feel like
it's an underrated pickup line
it's also kind of intrusive but it's
like come here mm-hmm
that's that does that work like the
perfect thing to say
how are the strip clubs out there are
they solid
i don't know ain't nobody no strip club
though
they're terrible in casey it's like
white [ __ ] dancing to nickelback type
[ __ ]
oh the laws i used to live in i did
radio in boise idaho and 09 and they it
was it was a joke
they weren't even strip clubs they were
just bikini boxes
they'd be coming to parties and [ __ ] but
like
right i'm not really like a strip club
type of [ __ ] like i don't go to strip
clubs nowhere no yeah i i i respect that
you want to keep your money
what are you gonna actually get from
going to the strip club absolutely i
mean you might you know you might tag
something but you're gonna walk out of
there a lot people are gonna look at you
and they're gonna know who you are and
if you don't throw money they're gonna
look at you like you're crazy and then
you're gonna be like i like my money
[ __ ] you
i'm here i'm here for the wings i'm here
for the lemon pepper i used to give my
bro no money to throw in that [ __ ] i
[ __ ] don't even do that just get lemon
pepper wings you said you went to a
studio at the strip club in indianapolis
i mean a strip club with a studio in it
that's [ __ ] impressive what [ __ ] was
that window
do we know the name of that place
indianapolis nap town what it was called
that's [ __ ] wild more people should
do that shake so let me did you record
there
nine get the record but did you go into
the studio yeah so how does that work if
you get the studio did the strippers
come in
like you can have the strippers come
back what kind of whack ass warm audio
mic did they have what was the setup was
it like a joke
solid okay you know it was hard the
studio was hard they're like yeah
technically we have a studio but it's a
focus right and like a 150 dollar mic
yeah that [ __ ] was definitely
wrong that'd be a great engineer gig to
have where you engineer at you know the
strip club you know
[ __ ] that's lit well look i appreciate
you pulling up man the record is going
crazy congratulations um and uh you got
new music coming the remix coming
it's coming hits
it's at the hits man this guy's no one
hit wonder no one here wonder i'ma show
y'all how to drop hits at the hits boom
sleazy world cup appreciate you bro